this is a this is a great video because
it has a lot of moving parts
um it's Brian Callan of course of course
uh Brendan Shaw star of Joker star of
Joker and the real star of the show Mark
Harley
is in this video too now for those who
don't know more plates more dates who's
[ __ ] awesome I love more place more
dates these [ __ ] great YouTube
channel recommend following him
um he went through the uh the liver King
thing and the emails and stuff like that
to this you know we talked about it all
the steroids he was taking whatever
I figured that the people that I really
want to know like what they think about
this are these gentlemen
now Derek plays more dates posted okay
right off the bat Derek from where now
Derek plays more dates
more plates
more dates more positive States no he
said it's more dates post no no hold on
now Derek plays more dates played some
more dates plates more dates posted uh
an email from liverkings is it his
doctor or is it bodybuilding coach it's
a big difference is it some advisor like
isn't there HIPAA laws here like isn't
this illegal isn't somebody gonna be
sued here uh was sent heavily redacted
emails from a bodybuilding coach who the
liver King was corresponding with it
wasn't with this one email
why use big word when small word will do
Mark Carly because you're a super
intellectual it was like back uh he was
corresponding uh semi-frequently uh like
once every Fortnight when I went to
Guadalajara
back and forth like tell me everything
about you you said he texted you once a
week yeah gonna be a bodybuilding coach
you have to know all these things
routine what they're taking now what
they want to take what their goals are
what their problem areas are give me
pictures of yourself doing these poses
um okay
yeah
the guy wearing those pants
yeah you're right he's a real [ __ ] which
he actually pushed back and he's like I
have no I don't know what these poses
are I need to do this in the next 30
minutes yeah this is one of the emails
but he
forwarded this on we don't know who that
person is he forwarded it on to Derek
um
and Derek went through all these emails
that would be more speculative if it was
just that you go maybe somebody
Photoshopped it but then Derek looked at
that email that sent the emails to this
bodybuilding coach and checked in his
own inbox and found that he had had
similar emails requesting consultations
on HGH and Annabelle from liver King
from uh you know this guy at ancestral
supplements whatever either Brian
Johnson or the liver kid whatever it is
but like we're presuming same email yeah
and also another email from somebody on
his team like asking something in that
vein too like but also it was before he
went public so it wasn't like in the
midst of his face I looked apart team
like yeah my money investing my time in
this I'm hiring a team like yeah we're
trying to reach 1 million followers like
with my positive message and he's like I
gotta you know look great like I looked
apart here's what I'm currently doing my
body's not responding to the HGH uh
igf-1 I'm taking 11 000 a month in uh
HGH which is overpaid okay but so it's
like and then he breaks down the rest of
all the [ __ ] if you don't bite in the
dark net you [ __ ] baboon
he's doing and I guess
but like like this was coming right like
we and then you and I had some blowback
because when liver King came on here
fans were like I can't believe you
didn't ask for if he's on steroids
listen
let me just say this this is not
a surprise that the way we all know
everybody knew and in fact it was always
tongue-in-cheek with this guy okay I
will agree with Brian Callan on this
because Brandon's about to go the other
way with that I woke up with Brian
Callan on this that everybody should
have known
but I think that the biggest issue that
people were having with this is not that
he was on steroids
the the problem always comes with this
kind of stuff it's not the dudes are on
steroids it's that dudes are on steroids
and then they're selling programs to
people and look yes we get that but
think about that an 18 19 year old kid
might not know you know they don't know
they're idiots that's where the problem
Lies when you tell an 18 19 year old kid
that you could look like a liver King if
you eat [ __ ] goat balls and [ __ ] you
know what I mean
look this guy Brian Johnson like that
whole joke that they always post on the
internet all you got to do is Trend hard
eat clam yep and Navar give up that's
all you got to do the the three it's the
Holy Trinity that's [ __ ] hilarious
and make sure you Club Med your way out
already you're not going to have kids
[Laughter]
some people look at that playing a
character this was a this was a
marketing thing he's been playing a
character uh it seems to have worked and
it was always done tongue-in-cheek at
the end of a tongue-in-cheek okay now I
don't lose Brian's losing me
if I go by the name of tiddlywinks or
whatever and then somebody asked me hey
bro you're jacked are you on steroids
that go no I can't later go well that
was my character tiddlywinks you ask not
me Royce of course I am or if you're
gonna do a tongue-in-cheek at least be
like yeah man I'm all Natty wink and
then you're like okay
and work out he's saying work out look
the best answer simply should always be
yes I am chemically enhanced you don't
even have to go into detail right I'll
get sun sleep and eat oh my God you
could have gotten out of it so much
easier you know they would have accepted
he's taking more than just trt but if we
just said yeah I'm on trt nobody would
have looked into it more no they would
have been like all right whatever who
cares eat another page good food but
when you look at his body no one was no
one was under the illusion if if you're
now like what I'm super excited to talk
I'm I'm gonna ask Rod nationalist who's
on tomorrow I'm going to ask him about
the liver King thing I'm curious what he
thinks then come on yeah absolutely good
and I got news for you Liberace was gay
so yeah
okay so exactly yeah like yeah Adam
Levine likes other women so the thing is
is with liver King like Adam what Adam
Levine yeah yeah yeah the the singer
yeah yeah let's check yeah I mean
he loves chicks you guys have been doing
a show too long not to be able to have
better chemistry than that guys come on
what was that you saw that
Adam who
you're living like six okay yeah he's
rock star right timepiece right
timepiece Papa
you keep that up we're gonna need new
chairs I'm getting new ones anyway don't
worry about it we're getting very angry
nothing like when I came out everyone's
like I can't believe I'm like oh wow I
don't realize how stupid people were I
mean
Brendan shop just said and I quote
I didn't realize how stupid people were
but even with him it's like when liver
King came on here if off the bat suck
this dick and didn't ask him any hard
questions you're like come on dude
you're on steroids right now he's
notoriously I mean he's denied it
anymore oh yeah on the count of all the
juice but he also talked about it like
wasn't it who said was it Logan Paul who
said why have you why don't you talk
about your steroid news somebody
somebody said Bradley Martin I think
Bradley Martin said what Bradley Martin
because I was talking Bradley yesterday
because Bradley's Bradley's in the
community he's like I don't get white
people are surprised he kind of like uh
kind of alluded to it on my paw
hey it's a secret word
I'm putting money inside finger chairs
break these chairs [ __ ] you it's a
podcast you pee brain and yeah the
problem with with liver King though I
also saw him go on other shows and say
that he was natural so shut the [ __ ] up
and stop pretending like he wasn't lying
like you know and I don't care if you're
on steroids by the way I don't give give
a [ __ ]
do it as a matter of fact especially if
you're over 40 [ __ ] it I say but just
don't lie about it until supplements
that's all kind of was like
but here's my thing with all this uh the
link to that that piece referencing and
no way shape or form did [ __ ] liver
King dude do what he's saying thank you
thank you virgin boom immediate
immediate fact checking there's a lot of
uh subprivals that are convinced that
liver King is taking steroids right and
this is this is what I'm asking I had
somebody come up to me in the elevator I
think it might have been the guy that
yelled at you this this is this is one
of my favorite [ __ ] topics is liver
King Maddie that's what he said yeah I
think he was like Tick Tock age they say
yeah well first thing I'm [ __ ] I'm
now you're giving me a Sidetrack but
I'll say this do you think if I was on
steroids I would have these [ __ ]
appendages down here these legs do you
see how [ __ ] little yeah you could
Skip Leg Day I mean no no no no no no
also do you see how little my legs are
and they're they're so [ __ ] huge
comparing I know what he's yeah upper
body is super jacked but his legs are in
really good shape like M James legs
aren't much bigger and his legs are
[ __ ] ridiculous now
my [ __ ] legs are you know
they're pretty oh pretty big okay well
let me [ __ ] go on here here's the
thing when I was in college I weighed
175 pounds and I was single digit body
fat I started working out about eight or
nine years old I had already been
working out for I don't know 10 or 12
years so now I'm 45 and I've gained less
than one pound a year
over 25 years less than one pound a year
it's not the amount of muscle you've
gained it's the amount of low body fat
at the Asians you've been able to
maintain while having that much muscle
on it but you know that yeah and also
honestly just being able to maintain the
muscle at this age yeah that's a good
point yeah your testosterone's gonna
crash dude you're gonna like look the
best example right is you can tell who
who weaned off a little bit I mean he's
still on [ __ ] but he's not on the big
boy [ __ ] anymore as John Cena oh he
pulled back baby
he's obviously gonna be on tear a few
the rest of his [ __ ] life yeah but he
pulled back on the HGH and the [ __ ]
the giant steroids and stuff and you can
watch John Cena from like 2011 and then
look at John Cena in like 2015. they're
two different body types and he's still
in great shape but he's like there was a
time when he was remember when he was
[ __ ] when he would come back from an
injury and he was just giant down his
[ __ ] hairline well you know that's
that happens and he got the old man bald
spot the back one
so this is what I say to people that
make this accusation accusations if you
don't believe this is possible then I
suggest that you take that self-limiting
belief you put that [ __ ] in a [ __ ]
box and you bury that next to all your
embarrassing [ __ ] and don't open your
[ __ ] mouth about it let that live
with you look at this and then you wish
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and then we saw that
[ __ ] half-assed limp rested apology
it's not that you lied about it it's
that you you [ __ ] attacked people for
being right
now look of course we knew he was on
steroids most people you know especially
dudes that you know merch and I watch
wrestling so we definitely [ __ ] you
could always tell you know when you have
a ginger Mahal who puts on 40 pounds in
three months you're like all right come
on man dude he just came back me bro he
just came back and you're like that
that's not gender moment yeah what the
[ __ ] this gyno is really bad titties
don't let that live with somebody else
because the highest and most dominant
form that we have to express is in front
of us right you hear people talk about
peaking the early 20s
I'm 45. if you look at Brian this is
liver King at 45 you look at Brian
Johnson at 20. liver King's gonna
[ __ ] murder that guy
insists on speaking in the third person
because it's all [ __ ] Carnival
[ __ ] jack off and it is true this
scene and out me definitely more Jesus
he lost all people he was much bigger
like he's still in great shape obviously
he's in amazing shape but but the thing
is is he wouldn't be in amazing shape if
he had just kept going [ __ ] full
throttle because eventually you're gonna
hit him even with all the [ __ ] drugs
in the world genetically you will just
hit a wall and it's always been dude
it's like it's like with steroids or CIT
or Royce always like we always talk
about [ __ ] uh like plastic surgery
right it's always best to wait as long
as until you need it as possible and
then do it because you'll get a nice
immediate [ __ ] benefit of it and
you'll go wow you look five years
younger this is fantastic right you'll
react much better to it but if you do it
when you're young and you do too much
when you're young and it's Non-Stop and
then you never stop you always end up
looking like some kind of living ghouls